est avec moi avec un criminaliste que
vous connaissez bien et maître
Marie-Pierre boulet président de
l'Association québécoise des avocats
avocats de la défense bonsoir à vous
deux bonsoir
sur le sur le côté très rapide de ça
qu'est-ce que ça vous dit comme expert
donc la preuve qui a été donnée
faisait en sorte que les jurys n'ont pas
eu beaucoup de doute sur la version de
la victime maître Marie-Pierre boulet
d'abord
je vous dirais évidemment que sur la
rapidité ça peut faire en sorte en fait
que rapidement pas nécessairement que
pas eu de doute là c'est peut-être
facile à dire parce que le résultat et
la culpabilité mais ça peut vouloir dire
que peu délibération c'est à dire que
les juristes entendent rapidement
sur la manière de mener le raisonnement
par exemple bon qu'est-ce qu'il fallait
madame boulet qui le qu'il décide
c'était quoi la question
essentielle donc le si je veux résumer
en termes non ça va là c'est lequel des
deux je crois en fait
en fait c'est surtout pas ça qu'il faut
faire parce que là ce serait un concours
de crédibilité alors sans utiliser les
termes savants il y a des termes
juridiques c'est-à-dire est-ce que je
vais très simplement est-ce qu'il
croyait ou non l'accusé s'il ne le crois
pas est-ce que quand même sa version
soulève un autre raisonnable et là
encore si l'ensemble la preuve avec lui
un témoignage de l'accusé mais celui
principalement de la plaignante disons
est-ce que la preuve est faite hors de
tout d'autres alors ce raisonnement en
trois étapes trois étapes importantes
que le juge leur a expliqué avant de
laisser délibérer bon mais Maître je dis
en deux mots ils ont cru ils ont cru la
victime ils n'ont pas cru arrête Lebel
il n'a pas soulevé d’autres raisonnable
dans l'esprit collectif du jury d'une
part alors là fallait regarder le reste
la preuve c'était pas une cause très
complexe on parle d'une soirée quelques
témoins des notions de droit qui sont
pas extrêmement complexes alors ça
explique aussi la rapidité et alors on
regarde le témoignage de est-ce que ça
nous satisfait hors de tout d'autres
raisonnable l'avocat de la défense avait
cherché à attaquer sa crédibilité sur
plusieurs éléments ça semble avoir été
écarté par le jury Monsieur Le Bel a été
trouvé coupable dans beaucoup d'autres
causes très médiatisées
la défense était le consentement souvent
les gens disaient mais dans le fond elle
voulait elle voulait puis ce n'est pas
vrai que ça a été une agression
puisqu'elle le voulait oh monsieur Lebel
est pas du tout elle est là c'est lui a
dit c'est pas arrivé est-ce que c'est
c'est plus difficile mettre José mais là
ça devient justement une affaire de
version contradictoire comme vous l'avez
bien résumé c'est pas comme si il y a un
incident et on s'entend sur ce qui s'est
passé mais je revendique une croyance
sincère au consentement elle dit qu'elle
n'a pas consenti mais moi j'avais des
éléments qui me tendaient qu'il faisait
en sorte que j'y pensais non c'est des
versions diamétralement opposées ce
qu'on appelle des versions
contradictoires et comme ma collègue
l'avait bien résumé il y a une formule
juridique qui n'est pas complexe que le
jury doit appliquer pour en arrivant à
verdict au final il n'a pas soulevé de
deux raisonnable et le témoignage de
madame était suffisamment limpé des
complets et crédible aux yeux du jury
pour être satisfait hors de tout
d'autres le témoignage de Madame
Marie-Pierre boulet était crédible comme
dit maître et José tenait la route
est-ce que c'est de nature à redonner
confiance aux victimes aux plaignantes
au système de justice en disant que
quand parce que là il y a personne qui
était là dans la pièce là c'est quand
même c'est risqué mais on a eu un
résultat clair et net dans ce cas-ci
en fait chacun peut tirer ses propres
conclusions vous avez je pense que
chaque col est un code espèce c'est
surtout ce qu'il faut retenir alors
évidemment dans ce cas-ci on peut
comprendre comme vous l'avez bien dit
c'est pas parce qu'on est le seul témoin
de notre propre cause que on peut la
perdre ou la gagner il y aurait quand
même pu monsieur Lebel de son côté
aurait pu aussi être à quitté tout en
ayant la crainte d’être lui-même le seul
témoin pour sa défense c'est pas une
question de force du nombre c'est une
question de fiabilité crédibilité de
force probante c'est des termes qu'on
emploie plutôt dans le domaine pour voir
qu'est-ce qui est retenu comme preuve
c'est ça mais Maître Jazy vous êtes pas
sans savoir que j'ai tout un débat
depuis des mois et des mois et des
années mais sur la perception du système
de justice et voici un cas clair qui va
certainement contribuer à dire à
beaucoup de femmes bon ben c'est
possible de faire toute cette preuve là
dans tout le processus judiciaire
alors ce que ce que le public peut
retenir c'est que si quelqu'un fait une
dénonciation il y a un encadrement là
pour porter plainte on est suivi à
travers ce processus et après ça la
justice suivra son cours comme ma
collègue le dit chacun est en cas
d'espèce il clamait son innocence il n'a
pas été cru elle a fait des allégations
elle a été cru au final chacun est
unique mais il y a un encadrement c'est
quelqu'un veut porter plainte elle ne il
y a des il y a des balises et on est la
personne elle est elle peut traverser le
processus en étant accompagné oui parce
que en fait ce que vous dites sans dire
c'est que c'est pas dans un autre cas
d'espèce un homme peut être acquitté
puis il a justice a été rendue aussi
bien je comprends bien ce que vous êtes
madame made boulet
appelle est-ce que on peut envisager un
appel ou c'est très dur dans ces
circonstances là rapidement mettre
boulet et mettre ici
en fait je voudrais que c'est plus
difficile dans un certain sens parce que
là le jury ne donne pas les raisons pour
lesquelles ils n'ont pas cru monsieur
level ou pour lesquels ils ont cru la
plaignante dans le dossier alors c'est
là que c'est plus complexe parce que si
on était devant un jeu seul et non pas
devant jury on pourrait attaquer les
éléments qui ont été retenus pour
favoriser le déversion je vais le dire
comme ça tandis qu'ici on va plutôt se
concentrer sur le travail quand on veut
aller de verdict de jury sur le travail
que le juge que président jury a fait
est-ce que les directives étaient bonnes
est-ce que le jury a été influencé
est-ce que les représentations qui ont
été faites par les parties étaient
conformes alors c'est plus circonscrit
comme question de droit qui peuvent être
soulevées en appel maîtrise vous êtes
d'accord oui en matière de crédibilité
c'est plus difficile aller en appel
c'est appartient vraiment aux jury la
pression de la crédibilité qui croire
qui n'a pas croire alors on verra ils en
train de jour mais avant de se rendre à
l'appel il approche un étape sera la
détermination de la peine alors on va
voir quels sont les positions
respectives devant le juge est-ce qu'il
va y avoir carcération non éclairez-moi
là-dessus est-ce qu'il risque d'avoir un
carcération aussi 10 ans le maximum dans
un crime comme ça Walid ouais ben c'est
pas possible c'est-à-dire la
jurisprudence mais l'en face sur la
dénonciation et la dissuasion après ça
il n'a pas d'antécédent judiciaire on
verra comment les avocats en particulier
tout ça au niveau de la peine c'est pas
une séance exacte et c'est un exercice
extrêmement délicat très bien merci à
vous deux de nous avoir éclairé merci
beaucoup c'est apprécié au revoir